Hi!
How are all of you?
Are we well?
Was it a good break?
Did we get food?
Are we refreshed?
Yes?
Really?
Let's try that again.
Yes?
There we go.
Excellent.
My name is Tejas, that's pronounced by contagious.
And I make that easy.
Is your name I get a lot of mispronunciations.
It is like contagious.
Don't worry, I'm not sick.
I'm not going to give you anything besides
hopefully a good talk about JavaScript and
its welcoming nature.
Day to day I work at a data science platform
called Contiamo.
And we build very rich, expressive user interfaces
that interact with machine learning and AI
to help users make better decisions, essentially
build decision tools.
What in the world?
I'm here today to talk to us about JavaScript.
Do I need to do something?
Especially how JavaScript as a language is
is helpful and welcoming and more hospitable
and accommodating to newcomers across the
board from beginners to intermediates to more
advanced engineers.
I'd really like to get the slides fixed.
It's throwing me off a bit.
Let's see.
Maybe should I not touch anything?
Right.
Okay.
The tech guys are on the way.
I guess I can just continue talking.
So, where were we?
Today we're going to talk about JavaScript.
The title of the talk is from you can't to
you can: The welcoming nature of JavaScript.
From you can't to you can: The welcoming nature
of JavaScript.
Have you ever felt like JavaScript has been
described or in some ways dismissed or reduced
as kind of a toy language?
As kind of it's a little bit brittle, it's
a little bit shaky.
Oh!
We have slides.
Excuse me.
That's cool.
Can we hear it for
[ Applause ]
All right.
Woohoo!
Thank you, sir.
The title, it's called you can't to you can:
The welcoming nature of JavaScript.
Right?
And so, we want to talk about how JavaScript
through various language syntax features is
just something that is so approachable and
hospitable and then talk about my experience.
So, make my point about JavaScript maybe being
a language that some consider brittle and
maybe not as robust, I would like to share
with you a quote from a friend of mine.
This quote and I think a good summation of
how we think about JavaScript.
Seriously?
There we go.
This is a heavy paraphrase of what a friend
of mine has said.
And it's heavy because it was way worse.
The original text.
Let me tell you.
He's a scholar engineer and really talented.
But fact of the matter is, some of the more
I'd say opinionated languages have in opinion
about JavaScript.
My goal today is to examine some points of
criticism about JavaScript and say, hey, maybe
that is not a bug.
But maybe that's a feature.
Do you understand?
Are you with me?
Maybe that's not a weakness, maybe it's a
strength.
Maybe it's not a disadvantage, but an advantage.
I want to talk to us particularly about four
things.
And then if we have some time at the end,
I would like to kind of share just a bit of
my story and experience with JavaScript.
With that, I would like to for two seconds
give us some context for those who haven't
heard talk two seconds about the history of
JavaScript.
So, and in the beginning the web platform
was really immature.
Or just beginning.
And, you know, the future of the web at the
time I think it was the '80s, I'm not even
sure, was foreseen as something that would
be powered by Java, right?
Java applets and browsers, web 2.0.
Wow, how cool?
Meanwhile, Netscape, Brendan Eich invented
this language that would be powerful and see
the web forward.
I read that this language took three weeks
to come up with.
And I've heard that it is it was a rush to
delivery.
Now, how many of us have written rush to delivery
code?
And I don't even need we know what that's
like, right?
I think while some would say that part of
JavaScript is maybe what makes it weak or
unique, I would say that may have been one
of the happiest accidents if it was an accident
in the history of our time.
And that's the reason I put the slide up there.
Now, let's get to the four things.
Number one.
I can already see some of the TypeScript people
in the room judging me.
But let me tell you, I think dynamic typing
with JavaScript is something that is weak
and that creates brittle applications, I have
honestly not seen a more welcoming construct.
Mainly because static typing as it stands
is extra syntax.
And there's a lot to keep track of.
I mean, this is from feedback from friends
of mine who were journalists, architects,
graphic designers with not a lot of web Dev
or computer science experience.
All of them wanting a change from what they
studied.
Guess what language they found a home?
Not TypeScript.
JavaScript by its nature of dynamic typing
was the language of choice.
I believe this is the reason.
I believe through the dynamic nature of the
language, what you get is the ability to go
from zero to, oh, my gosh, it's working, in
a fraction of the time it would normally take.
I would also say that dynamic typing is educational.
Absolutely educational.
And what I mean by that is it teaches you
the need for static typing.
Right?
How many of you have been bitten by implicit
coercion?
You try to do a computation and you get a
nan, what can occur with the explicit JavaScript
conversion because of the dynamic type system.
What happens is really cool and something
that I believe is unique to the JavaScript
community.
JavaScript as a syntax I would say is really,
really, really friendly for the reasons we
discussed.
But I would say that's two sides of the same
coin.
The other side being the helpful, supportive,
inclusive community that I'm looking at right
now.
If someone's bitten by a typing error in JavaScript,
or just a computation that's impossible, what's
the next step?
You turn to StackOverflow or GitHub or something.
Or discord and you find a community.
That's because you're changing this thing.
Whatever the cause may be.
And you learn.
I grew up in a school setting where information
was ingested and then regurgitated practically
and professionally.
So, you learn things.
And then you just do it in your job.
That's just the way it's always been.
That's what we have learned.
I would argue when you have bitten by a few
dynamic type problems, you learn the need
and the importance of it and use it wisely.
Number two.
This is a quote that should not have happened.
We'll talk about that in a second.
Number two.
This is an excerpt bit author of a book called
JavaScript: The good Parts.
The author is one of the greatest contributors
for the community.
He worked for Yahoo! and created a UI kit,
and this is what he says about JavaScript
APIs from the browser and from Node.
JavaScript is coupled with the DOM, a horrendous
API, before NodeJS.
A lot of confusion about where JavaScript
ends, and the DOM begins.
While I would agree with the second part,
I don't see why the DOM is particularly a
horrendous API.
In fact, I would say the DOM is the reason
I have a job.
The DOM is the reason for many of our careers
here.
Especially if you work with like React or
VUE or something.
We have a React fan!
VUE fan.
We have a UI fan.
[ Laughter ]
I would argue APIs, at least for me and other
engineers who have started have been just
these building blocks, right?
From which you can show a pop up or a modal
dialogue or accept user input using window.prompt.
You can fetch data using the fetch API.
It's declared.
There was a talk at CSS Conf with declarative
CSS where it's a declarative algorithm.
The APIs give you this tool set in the browser
and in Node that gets you up and running really
fast.
It's part of the welcoming nature of JavaScript.
I was willing to admit for me as a junior
engineer, I tried to use window and Node.
It gave me an error.
Window is not a function you can use it in
JavaScript?
I confused it for syntax.
But, again, the community shown, and I learned,
and I was able to learn.
In fact, I have spent a lot of time talking
about APIs.
And really this talk is largely community
based.
It's not very technical.
But I thought, you know, since I'm talking
about APIs, I might as well use one.
I wanted to build something.
What I ended up doing was thinking about what
can I build?
And I thought about, well, you know, I really
like talking in case you can't tell, and I
really like people.
And I don't want to have to hide behind the
podium and change the slides.
Or use a clicker.
I just thought I could build something that
as I'm talking, it would follow me through
my slides.
And that's basically what's been happening
this whole time.
Hello.
My name
[ Applause ]
It's just the JavaScript ecosystem is so rich
with these APIs.
I built this thing.
I put it on GitHub.
It's called Praise.
And it's very it's open source.
It's very experimental.
Please do not use it in production.
It's only supported in Chrome.
But it's literally just to make a point.
And that point is, JavaScript is welcoming.
Praise was the praise.
See?
It's experimental.
That was the projects.
APIs how long did this take?
I sat next to my girlfriend, this beautiful
young lady here.
Took me four hours on a Saturday afternoon.
I was at it, I made bindings for it.
Why not?
All of that's on GitHub.
Number three.
JavaScript, I have been heard JavaScript criticized
as an unopinionated language.
You can write whatever style of code you want
and that's the language.
You can write class based, object oriented,
polymorphic, inherited style code, or stateless
functional immutable code with monads flying
around that looks like math.
And there's no real it doesn't push you into
a style.
I have heard in this from Golang engineers.
If
you peek under the hood of JavaScript, it
is, in fact, opinionated.
I have written object oriented, polymorphic
inherited style code, and there's a use case
for that.
But you get functions and objects and things
that use prototype delegation.
And so, this would lead me to think, JavaScript
is kind of sort of leading towards more of
a functional language.
You get first class functions.
You get recursion out of the box.
There's a star there.
I know, I know not everything is a function.
But you catch my drift.
And then in a team, you can kind of conventionalize
the other functional best practices.
You can have pure functions, immutable data
structures.
And go on and on and on.
I would say JavaScript is easier this way.
When I tried writing code kind of Java style,
what ended up happening is I felt like I was
going up an escalator that was moving down.
Are you tracking with me?
It felt like I was fighting the language.
The way I use the language, the way I would
say it was designed, things got a lot easier.
The last thing I'll say is really, I mean,
it's there was a point of controversy for
a little bit last year.
I'm to the going to say much about it.
Because in my opinion it is incredible.
It is the greatest mechanic a compiler can
have.
I guarantee you.
Lastly, we'll talk about my slides don't change.
It's experimental.
Don't use it in production.
We'll talk about this.
Automatic semicolon insertion is such a blessing
for beginning developers.
Have you worked in another language and left
off the semicolon and the compiler yells at
you?
Why?
Am I not allowed to make a mistake?
Gosh.
Yet JavaScript, if it's someone just learning,
what does it do?
It just says, I see what you're trying to
do.
I got you.
If there's one thing you get from this talk,
let it be that JavaScript is your bro.
Or sis.
Or whatever, gender neutral.
And so, those are the four things that I think
really help JavaScript be this language that
is so easy to adopt across the board.
About ASI, I'll say one more thing.
As I've learned and grown into a more seasoned
engineer, I would recommend leave your semicolons
on.
Honestly, it's good as a starting out step
to make have the optional.
But you're fighting the compiler under the
hood by not having them.
Now that that's out of the way, let's shift
gears a little bit.
And I would like to talk about my journey
with JavaScript.
Because you see in many ways it is a journey
of from you can't to you can.
I was born with a disability.
I was born with a disease.
As I said in the beginning, I'm not contagious,
don't worry.
But it's still a disease.
And it is life threatening.
And I have been told I have the worst kind
of it.
Basically, the condition is called hemophilia.
Do not confuse that with homophobia.
But hemophilia is a disease where once I start
bleeding I do not stop until I lose all my
blood and die.
And so, I mean, I can see some of you engineers
in the room go, well, then, just don't get
cut.
Problem solved, dude.
It's not rocket science.
But let me tell you, internal bleeding is
something that is far more common than external
bleeding.
And so, if you've walked today, if you came
with a backpack.
I guarantee you you have started bleeding
into your niece or ankles or elbows.
But you stop.
So, you don't even notice.
I've been in the emergency room literally
by opening a heavy door.
I have by climbing stairs.
I've literally spent weeks in the emergency
room.
And so, this you can see by this how you can
get a lot of you can'ts.
Am I right?
You can't play sports.
You can't ride a bicycle.
I have a bicycle.
To this day I have no idea what to do with
it.
It just sits there.
I probably should sell it.
Who wants to buy a bike?
You want it?
Really?
We'll talk after.
I so, there's a lot of you can'ts.
And that started to change when we brother,
who is healthy, he went to an HTML class.
And when I was 8 years old, he came home,
and he showed me.
He was like, look what I learned.
He wasn't as interested.
But I was like, are you kidding me?
I can make a UI?
What I was so interested.
What ended up happening was he would go to
school and my parents would go to work and
I would be alone at home all day every day
most of the year.
And an entire school year I would attend 19
days of school.
The rest of the time I'm alone at home doing
what?
Well, there's so many games you can play and
cartoons you can watch.
And candy you can eat until you get bored.
And when you're bored, I've learned, you do
what interests you.
And for me, this was code.
So, I started writing some code and made a
couple websites as a child.
I was in magazines.
If there's child making websites in a small
town, people hear.
I was in a few magazines and then my parents,
god bless them, they did the best thing they
need to do.
They put me in an advanced program for object
oriented C++ at age 10.
At age 10.
I still have the diploma.
And I'm like, I don't remember any of it.
Right?
As a 10 year old I'm sitting there with all
kinds of includes at the top of the file.
#include.cone io.h.
Is there ice cream in the program?
I had no idea.
The compiler would yell at me for everything.
As a 10 year old, I'm sitting there going,
why is it yelling at me?
I'm writing code.
Is this another thing I can't do?
I thought programming was my thing.
People have applauded me.
You can't, you can't, you can't.
And now I thought I could.
Eventually I got back into JavaScript as it
evolved and things like Prototype and query,
and things started picking up traction.
And I won an award for web development in
my home town.
And not long after a job came and another
job.
And I'm interviewing all of a sudden for a
position in Germany.
Move here.
And now, let me tell you, I have access to
the best health care I have ever received.
I go running.
I lift weights, I've climbed mountains.
I go rafting in the river.
It's insane.
And all of a sudden most of the "You can'ts"
have become the" You can" largely because
thank you.
Yeah.
You can go for it.
[ Applause ]
Largely largely because of the welcoming nature
of JavaScript.
Let me tell you, we have a language that is
inclusive.
That is tolerant.
That will not entangle your mind with intersection
types and discriminated unions and generics.
While these are good things.
There is a time and a place.
We have a language that is inclusive.
That is easy.
On the other side of the coin, we have a community
can we hear it for the community?
[ Applause ]
We have a community, man, is it inclusive?
Look around you.
This looks like the United Nations here, right?
We have a community that is inclusive.
That is tolerant.
That is mostly vegan.
I'll leave you I will leave you with this.
I've thoroughly enjoyed our time together.
I've thoroughly enjoyed working even with
the organizers of this conference to make
it a wonderful time.
They have given me a wonderful time more I
haven't organized anything.
Don't get me wrong.
But I'll leave you with this.
I think we have the potential to make the
language what it is how many of you have heard
the TC39 talk?
Right.
Exactly.
TC39 shapes the language and it is an open
standard.
It is an open source project with proposals.
Contribute.
Get involved.
You have the power to make the language what
you want it to be.
If you don't want to code, you have the power
to make the community what it is.
You have the power.
I leave up the slide for Praise if any of
you are interested.
It should change.
If it doesn't change, whatever.
But thank you very much.
That's my talk.
[ Applause ]